LAUREN BLANCHARD IS LIVE FROM
D.C. WITH THE CHAOS.
LAUREN?
REPORTER: GOOD MORNING.
DAYLIGHT HOURS AT THE MARCH
REMAIN LARGELY PEACEFUL WITH
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PRO-TRUMP
SUPPORTERS IT WAS AFTER THE SUN
WENT DOWN THINGS TOOK A MUCH
UGLIER TONE.
>> FIREWORKS!
FIREWORKS!
FIRE WORKS!
REPORTER: COUNTERPROTESTERS
CLASHED WITH THOSE WHO TURNED
OUT FOR THE PRESIDENT EVEN
THROWING FIREWORKS.
THERE WERE FISTFIGHTS THROUGH
ALL OUT BRAWLS WHICH STRETCHED
INTO THE EARLY HOURS THIS
MORNING.
OVERALL THERE WERE 20 ARRESTS
ACCORDING TO THE MAYOR’S OFFICE.
AT LEAST SEVEN GUNS WERE
RECOVERED.
ONE MA IS STABBED HE IS EXPECTED
TO BE ALL RIGHT.
BREAKDOWN OF 10 A ARRESTS MADE
EARLIER YESTERDAY.
THEY INCLUDE FIREARM VIOLATIONS,
SIMPLE SOUGHT, ASSAULT ON AN
OFFICER, AND DISORDERLY CONDUCT.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED ABOUT THE
CHAOS, WRITING RADICAL LEFT
ANTIFA SCUM WAS EASILY REBUFFED
BY THE D.C. MAGA RALLY CROWD, TO
RETURN AT NIGHT AFTER 99% OF THE
CROWD HAD LEFT TO ASSAULT
ELDERLY PEOPLE AND FAMILIES.
POLICE GOT THERE BUT LATE.
MAYOR IS NOT DOING HER JOB.
WE’RE ALSO TOLD THERE WERE TWO
POLICE OFFICERS WHO WERE INJURED
AND WE’RE HOPING FOR AN UPDATE
LATER ON THIS MORNING IF WERE
ANY ADDITIONAL ARRESTS AND ANY